hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
there's something about horror games
that keeps us coming back for more maybe
it's the satisfaction of surviving a
zombie horde or enduring a near-death
experience there's a huge chunk of
people who can't get enough suspense and
horror and done for blood and guts to
here's my pick for 10 games that will
scare the [ __ ] out of you can I say I've
said now so move on I've also made this
list because there's a few titles that
are in development hell and could use
our attention a good horror game isn't
just for Halloween folks it's the life
let's start with the remake of Resident
Evil 2 and don't make my mistake if you
see one of those things uniform or not
you do not hesitate depending on whether
if you played the original which came
out 20 years ago you'll know how
frightening it can be in the corridors
of Raccoon City Police Department in the
remake Clare and Leon both returned with
a few updates from 1998 now powered by
the engine used to create Resident Evil
7 the re to remake seas environments
extremely lifelike and far more
realistic especially with the added
lighting this is going to be pumped
wetting Li tents gone are the fixed
camera angles from the 1990s replaced
with an over-the-shoulder shot which
adds to the immersion as you are never
quite sure what's behind your back one
of the founders of survival horror has
been updated but with just enough of the
original mechanics which made Resident
Evil the pinnacle zombie experience the
Resident Evil 2 remake releases on ps4
PC and Xbox on January the 25th I'll be
playing it here on the channel if you
don't want to experience it all on your
own
let's keep the zombie inspired vibe
going with the Last of Us part 2 if you
played the original from back in 2013
you'll know that this isn't survival
horror as you'd expect it The Last of Us
was a narrative masterpiece stitched
together with constant threat of a
single bite ending your playthrough and
by the end of the game we all realize
that human beings are the real enemies
here The Last of Us part 2 continues
those sentiments and follows are now
grown up le the fight scenes are even
more tense than in the first game with
added mechanics such as hiding in long
grass and prey they don't look for you
where you're hidden
escaping under vehicles ready to strike
and literally taking arrows out of your
enemies to use in your trusty bow the
Last of Us part two takes survival style
action-adventure to another level as I'm
writing this it's uncertain if part two
will release in 2019 or 2020 fingers
crossed it's the former and just in case
you weren't aware the Last of Us part 2
is only available on PlayStation 4 and
likely the PlayStation 2
[Music]
did you play the silent hill's demo a
few years back it was great but sadly
the game was cancelled and we all moved
on with a heavy heart luckily that
project inspired Allison wrote the worst
thing I want to do right now is play a
game the indie project looks so similar
to silent hill's that it was thrown into
the limelight without really being ready
and subsequently it was canceled twice
three years later their website stopped
updating content and their social media
went dark this may be a shot in the dark
but could 2019 bring arson Road back
into the public eye we'll have to wait
to find out but I'm not ready to say
goodbye to this indie Kickstarter what
do you think happened to Allison Road is
it dead or waiting to pounce around the
next corner
[Applause]
whoa whoa you are trying to force the
door you nosy prick easy sir all right
put down the X you know how we do it
rather like you we got them
dump them into the ocean whoa do you
know the legend of the Cthulhu it's like
an octopus dragon thing but other people
describe it differently back in the
1920s author HP Lovecraft great name
released this yacht story named the Call
of Cthulhu and since that day the legend
has grown and now 90 years later Call of
Cthulhu the official video game is ready
to strike the plot follows Edward Pierce
a good old private investigator who
looks into the death of an entire family
on dark water Island little does he know
the impending revival of the Cthulhu is
about to happen this could be another
game in development hell but after a
period of two years without stub date
the horror story was set to release in
2017 obviously that didn't happen but we
are now fast approaching the next
anticipated release of October the 30th
2018 many people are skeptical about
that date but from what we've seen this
stealth infused psychological horror
title is worth the wait
this was supposed to be easy just track
her down again bring her home
and how far I would really have to go
someday you'll return is an upcoming
psychological horror game developed by
CBE software which is hugely inspired by
the story of Silent Hill the developer
also notes outlast to the vanishing of
Ethan Carter and Resident Evil 7
biohazard as inspiration we've only seen
a glimpse so far with the release date
being a vague 2019 if someday you'll
return can take elements from all those
great horror franchises then we're in
for a treat in 2019
[Music]
this is ad infinitum how's your Latin
ahora video game based in the trenches
of World War would experienced in
first-person we're creatures of darkness
lurk in the shadows
we'll be surviving the battlefield
trench warfare and solving puzzles to
progress the story the atmosphere is
paramount in horror titles and ad
infinitum has it in abundance
please horror gods don't let this game
be canceled anew horror title first
announced that 2018 games Khan is close
to the Sun set in the 19th century
around the skills of Nikola Tesla and
his thirst to create new things we take
control of Rose a journalist who is
attempting to write a story and end up
being trapped in this facility she must
find out what went wrong and how she can
survive this nightmare this has a vibe
like Bioshock and massive inspiration
from steampunk it could be promising
close to the Sun releases early in 2019
on ps4 and PC
[Music]
asymmetric horror games were all the
rage last year with Friday the 13th and
dead by daylight being the highlights
Battle Royale is the current trend which
brings us to a horror game that smashes
both concepts together headfirst hide or
Die 15 players start out in a nuclear
bunker and once the doors open they must
be the sole survivor and reached the
exit without being killed by traps are
being consumed by the darkness one
player takes control of the hunter who
is tasked with taking down all the
survivors the hunter then takes on the
final survivor in a tense one-on-one
battle as there can be only one as this
game is in such an early state it will
take quite a while for it to reach us on
console but Steam users keep an eye on
their steam page for weekly updates
here's one I'm quite excited about how
about a cooperative horror game
[Applause]
The Blackout Club is set to release in
2019 up to four players take on the role
of teenagers looking to find out what's
going on in their town they discover
people are sleepwalking at night and
will use different skills to progress
the storyline each character has a
different skill set all this is
happening with the presence of a stalker
who can pounce at any moment when the
shape catches you it turns you into a
sleepwalker but on the third strike you
die little else is known at this point
but blackout Club looks damn good and it
has me hyped but what do you think
there's so many more horror games we
could have included in this list such as
Madison's gone moons of madness but I
think this list has enough variety for
any self-respecting horror fan but what
are your favorites the re to remake and
blackout club look great to me I'm Adam
from PlayStation granade it's been a
bloody pleasure like always I'll see you
next time
[Music]